he says to Muhammad hijab it's not I
don't do hypotheticals but in this clip
that I'm going to show you now he has a
hypothetical situation of identifying
himself as a black
lesbian so guys if you are somebody who
trains like me when I'm doing boxing
when I'm jogging when I'm do
bodybuilding this can benefit you it's
from Nature's Blends as you guys
know I get my honey my black seed oil
and many other supplements from them it
has 86 plus minerals including zinc
magnesium selenium fic acid 59% fully
lab tested the highest in the market
boost testosterone levels Boost energy
levels and safe for men and women so
check out Nature's Blends in the
description box and enjoy
itam brothers and sisters and dear
friends yes I look a bit different today
uh I am in Mecca and I don't get a
chance to wear clothing like this so I
make the most out of it while I'm here
cuz in the UK If I do some family
members might call
MI5 anyways that's a different story
today's video is about Piers Morgan he
had a debate with Muhammad hijab and we
all know how that went he got finished
by Muhammad
hijab putting that aside brothers and
sisters when Muhammad was asking him a
question a hypothetical scenario of UK
being under attack by just he's just G
an example of Imagine a group of people
in a specific part of the UK were under
attack and P Morgan had to say this
let's watch for oursel inshallah if they
did is it acceptable they never went in
and kidnapped grandmothers or kill
babies in is it acceptable or not they
believe they were fighting for better or
worse and I believe for worse and that's
why I'm glad peace was found you asked
about the analogy of a plane flying over
targeting but you didn't answer my
question but that did happen Muhammad
with Isis would you accept Belfast to be
flattened wait minute or not yes wait a
minute it never happen so the like for
like isn't it's a hypothesis
hypothetical it's not it's not I don't
do hypotheticals don't do hypothe no no
let's deal with reality okay let's deal
with reality let me let me finish so
guys what you saw there is that when it
comes to these situations when he knows
that he is cornered he has no way out
and I'll be honest I genuinely believe
he was threatened by his employers he
would lose his job if he was to condemn
Israel a country that is apide and not
only that is massacring hundreds of kids
50% of the population of Gaza are
children but when it comes to this
scenario he says to Muhammad hijab it's
not I don't do hypotheticals I don't do
hypothetical scenarios but in this clip
that I'm going to show you now for some
odd reason he has a hypothetical
situation of identifying himself as a
black lesbian it's fine when it's when
it comes to proving his point when it
comes to um him trying to prove a point
he will give a hypothetical scenario or
a situation to make his point but when
Muhammed does the same to expose Israel
Israeli occupiers that's what they are
they are thieves they are occupiers they
are terrorists that's what they are for
that matter watch in this clip what he
says but if anyone according to you can
identify as a woman anyone can right I
don't see a problem with literally put
the hand up say I'm a woman it's not an
easy thing to do to go out into the
world very easyy you might think it's
easy to say but to decide to do that to
say this is involve whatever that person
decides but to go out into the world and
say I I don't identify as perhaps the
sex why can't I identify okay why can't
I identify as a black
lesbian well first I mean it I'm serious
I'm serious if I can identify as
anything without any need to prove I'm
actually what that is why can't I on
International women say say I'm pe's
Morgan I'm a black lesbian I think
taking it to a kind of absurd status
where talking about quite with respect I
think that You' already opened the
absurdity door by saying it is Limitless
you can do what you like anyone can say
I'm a woman so I simply ask you why
can't I so guys you heard for yourself
when it is a Muslim that is talking
against oppression and Injustice Piers
Morgan does not want to know he doesn't
want to know he doesn't care about any
situation for that matter and you can
see the double standards and hypocrisy
and that's why we know the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam told
us that when these evildoers these
disbelievers hostile ones when their
soul is being taken out the angels will
be calling them by the most violence
names why because the prophet said that
a person who spreads a lie and that lie
spreads so far Subhan Allah that it it
it spreads this misinformation Subhan
Allah and he tells us about the
punishments that this individual will
get and be known as a liar and this is
what's going to happen do not ever
brothers and sisters think that these
people who are doing these stuff
Injustice oppression which they Can See
Clearly for themselves the whole world
sees it and they know very well Israel
this occupiers are losing the battle one
rule when it comes to proving his point
another rule for somebody else where
he's trying to show where Muhammed was
trying to clear to show an example where
he knew very well he would have to
condemn he said it's not I don't do
hypotheticals I don't deal with
hypothetical situations he's been
exposed again brothers and sisters and
do not Despair and have trust in Allah
subhana wa tala like Allah says in the
Quran do not ever think with this matter
sometimes our believe in Allah comes to
question do not ever Allah says don't
ever think Allah is unaware of what the
evil doers do he only delays them for a
day that their eyes will look in horror
the greatest Justice is going to be done
in that day brothers and sisters nothing
that can be done in this life would be
enough for these individuals on when you
see and we will see the evildoers
getting what they deserve is the day
where you will say that Allah knew what
we did not knew like Allah said to the
angels when they asked them are you
going to make a group of people who are
going to cause Bloodshed on Earth he
said I know what you don't know so in
these times we need to have and Trust in
Allah subhana wa tala that do not ever
think that they are going to get Scot
free in Go scotf free that's all I
wanted to say share this video inallah
to show the double standards and
hypocrisy of Pierce Morgan and many like
him the truth will always
prevail